(dubstep music)
- No offense, but air quality
in China is not great.
People are actually buying
bottled Canadian air
for big bucks.
LA air is crap too.
We've got a natural-gas leak
that won't be fixed for months.
People here love to be organic AF,
so I've come up with an ingenious
product for LA citizens:
artisanal air,
fresh, organic, single-sourced.
Take a whiff;
you deserve it.
- Oh, you wanna sit in that chair?
Cool, me too.
Actually I don't like sharing.
Get the (beeping) out of my chair.
(cat meowing)
- It's the new year.
I wanna be eating more vegetables.
I want them to be super-colorful;
so I came to a grilled cheese place
to make the most colorful
grilled cheese sandwich
I could ever make.
- [Man] We'll start with red peppers.
Ah! Carrot slaw, carrot slaw.
American cheese?
- [Lynn] Yeah!
Arugula?
- [Lynn] Root for spice?
- [Eric] Is it possible
- [Lynn] Do you...
In the world of food?
But you have blue cheese.
What we do is we make
a blue-cheese spread.
(spry lively orchestral music)
(sizzling)
- [Lynn] What just happened here?
I asked for vegetables.
I got a grilled cheese sandwich.
- That happens around me.
- [Lynn] This is the pot of
gold at the end of the rainbow.
So for those of you trying to
eat more vegetables in 2016,
I highly recommend doing
it in grilled-cheese form.
- [Man] Gavon, was today
a good day or bad day?
- Oh!
It was a good day!
- [Man] Why?
- Well first of all, North Korea claims
they tested an H-bomb,
but I'm not convinced
it's anything other than
a viral promotional stunt
for the next Godzilla movie.
There was a press conference in Oregon
by a Native American tribe
who thought it was pretty rich
that all of these white
European dudes in beards
are claiming they are the
original owners of the land.
Also there's a big puddle in England
that everybody's freaking out about.
So all in all, a banner day.
- [Man] (laughing)
(funky electronic music)